IT IS TIME TO PLAY MARQUEE DE
FAIL.
MARQUEE DE FAIL.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: AS A GREAT MAN ONCE
SAID--ME, JUST NOW--ON THE
INTERNET, ANYTHING CAN FAIL.
FROM CATS TO CAKES, EVERY ASPECT
OF THE HUMAN EXPERIENCE CAN BE
PUT ONLINE AND MOCKED
MERCILESSLY.
AND, YES, ALSO MOVIE MARQUEES.
IS NOTHING SACRED?
>> SO WE WILL SHOW YOU A CINEMA
SIGNAGE FAIL THAT INADVERTENTLY
CREATED A MUCH MORE INTERESTING
NEW MOVIE.
FOR 250 POINTS, YOU'RE GONNA
GIVE US A TAGLINE FROM THAT
NEW MOVIE.
LINCOLN, BULLET TO THE HEAD.
PAUL.
>> YOU CAN'T REWRITE HISTORY.
>> Chris: YES. POINTS.
APRIL.
>> "A TOUR DE FORCE," SAYS JOHN
WILKES BOOTH.
>> Chris: POINTS.
RON.
>> ARE YOU A RACIST WHO JUST
WANTS TO GET TO THE GOOD PART?
>> THE GOOD PART.
THE GOOD PART.
>> Chris: POINTS TO RON
FUNCHES.
NEXT ONE.
FOCUS, GET HARD, AMERICAN
SNIPER.
>> RON.
>> SOLDIER FINDS OUT HIS TRUEST
BATTLE IS FIGHTING THE MONOTONY
OF MARRIAGE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
APRIL.
>> THE STORY OF ONE MAN WHO
COULDN'T YANK HIS DOODLE
DANDY.
>> Chris: VERY WELL DONE.
>> I AM SORRY.
I CAN SEE THAT ON A BILLBOARD.
>> Chris: POINTS.
NEXT ONE, THOR: THE D.
>> MR. FUNCHES.
>> DO YOU THINK YOU ARE WORTHY
ENOUGH TO HOLD IT?
>> Chris: POINTS.
PAUL.
>> HE IS HAMMERING HIS WAY
THROUGH THE ALPHABET.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS.
NEXT ONE.
THE WRATH OF THE TIT.
>> Chris: PAUL.
>>HERE'S MILK IN YOUR EYE.
>> Chris: RON.
>> FROM THE MAKERS OF THOR: THE
D.
>> Chris: POINTS.
LAST ONE, TRANSFORMERS SEX TAPE.
>> RON FUNCHES.
>> HEY, DO YOU WANT TO SEE
(BLEEP)ING ROBOTS (BLEEP)ING
ROBOTS?
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> WO, WA.
>> Chris: APRIL.
>> LOTS OF EXPLOSIONS...TO THE
FACE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
MR. TOMPKINS.
>> ROBOTS IN THIS GUY.
>> THAT'S ONE OF MY FAVORITES.
>> Chris: POINTS.
ALL RIGHT.
THE DIGITAL TEAM, CAN YOU GUYS
SHOW THEM THAT THING YOU MOCKED
UP? I KNOW IT IS JUST SUPPOSED
TO BE FOR US BUT CAN YOU SHOW
IT?
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> THAT'S HOW THEY DO IT.